comment activer ces questions qu'elle
tient dans le printemps parce qu'on n'a
même pas eu le temps de talent heures à
19 heures 30 à 19 heures voilà deux
doigts de le faire gisèle va venir nous
rejoindre et gilles verdez vous avez le
temps des quatre tirs pour décider ce
que vous voulez faire le saut ou pas en
fin d'émission vous êtes déjà en tenue
on peut le voir ce que c'est pas votre
tenue voilà de vilain ça bien entendu si
ça alors je vous jure c'est les arbitres
très très bien on verra ça fait beaucoup
d'action et garonne joyau claudine c'est
bien aller jean luc lemoine alors les
questions qui obtient alors peut-être
que vous nous rejoignez seulement pour
ce printemps que vous ne connaissez pas
l'émission sachez qu'on est là tous les
jours en direct sur des 8 à 18h45
jusqu'à plus soif en ailleurs puisque
l'émission termine de plus en plus tard
merci je vais aller s'est déroulé à
terme étaient prêts à donner de jean luc
lemoine et jean luc lemoine et vous
montre tout ce qui se passe en coulisses
dans cette émission
tout ce qu'on voit pas tout ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs tout ce qui se
peut se dire toutes les toutes les
petites toutes les bassesses 1 voilà qui
sont équipés de ces gens des héros
également des héros attention jean luc
lemoine genre second c'est les questions
que c'est une question qui vous concerne
le plus grand des héros c'est qui bah
c'est pas moi eh ben on va y regarder la
question bonjour je m'appelle eliane je
trouve que cherry hanouna et ce qui est
arrivé de mieux en télévision depuis
qu'un mini dont je voulais savoir
comment fait-il pour être aussi brillant
je vous comprends eliane cc c'est vrai
qu'à l'instar de kazimierz qu'il est lui
aussi un monstre gentille alors comment
fait il pour être aussi brillant déjà
vous le voyez il est nature les invités
il les reçoit bien comme regarder
minimatic pas je les adore venir willy
nom mé alé lô ces derniers pourquoi
quand même j'ai kiffé bah oui mais vous
croyez que les 1000 mathis et fait ce
mac et sur beaucoup de plateau un quoi
bah non non non elle s'est pas fait en
espagne et sur beaucoup de plateau ça
c'est de l'accueil messieurs dames et de
la générosité
parce qu'un baiser de cyril ça se
déguste aussi après kiss qui a quand
même
c'est rien c'est les poêles à bois
s'il te plaît billy si tu nous regardes
franchement envie mais est ce que tu
peux pas mettre un tweet pour lui dire
tu as qui fait parce que sinon il va pas
me croire mais vigiles te plaît voilà si
quelqu'un appelle mimi pour lui dire
voilà quelqu'un faisait peu twitté parce
que sinon il va y va à mon goût il va
alors tu es qui fait mais d'après les
experts ne nous a laissé trois poils un
mélomane 1 vous savez par exemple il
connaît par coeur tous les chansons des
worlds apart
ouais enfin je crois que c'est des
paroles à peu près en tout cas ça n'a
pas choqué du tout il est belmont ibos
que cette version de caen je rêve de
thouars et théo n'ont pas d'état
tout
quand je re
mais pas si jeune que ça
celestica plus mal tomber
on est et on était dans les rondes
étaient plats sautés n'aura fait un truc
de fou jean michel maire aussi l'hôte il
a sauté dedans on était bien et là et
bam
elle était héroïque heureusement n'aura
été là pour amener un petit peu de
dignité dans cette émission c'est moi
isabelle mais parce que moi je vous aime
c'était un honneur alors en pleine
dépression mais en tout cas bercy et
devra en plus je vais pas trahir un
secret est normale elle n'aime pas
vraiment les worlds apart
c'est vrai attends attends pas tant que
ça noël est ce qu'il préfère c'est john
mamann nom et son tube love life
ah j'adore un an que non
et sous un tas et
on parle bien sûr de l'animal un
baladeur évidemment vient toujours avec
son animal oui non si rien est un
personnage étrange que nas en un mot
c'est un morpion
alors quand il veut savoir quelque chose
c'est un comble lorsque vous mettez dans
la gueule groupimo enfin non mais
désormais c'est quand il veut ça a
quelque chose il a jamais le morceau
alors un des conseils pour vous que
faire si vous vous retrouvez face à lui
qui vous interroge n'essayez pas de
résister ça ne sert à rien un seul
parent valable en cas d'urgence c'est de
lui diffusées du shy'm c'est imparable
ça lui fait tout oublier ouais non parce
que si je le dis tu es le répéter dans 5
minutes de jeu ce genre dit la vérité
j'ai pas de meuf dit la vérité
tout l'imaginaire afrique en
interrogatoire chez moi est ce que oui
c'est vous la nuit du 22 au 23 et je
n'aime pas les protocoles j'ai baptisé
le gallou puis tout laisser tomber et
c'est bon il est innocent il est
innocent et vous voulez moi j'ai
toujours un mp3 de shy'm chez moi en cas
d'attaqué de césar alors cyril nous
fascine tous vous les savez enfin
surtout les autres qui échafaudent
beaucoup de théories sur lui comme une
aura mais ça je préfère pas vous le
montrer non car je sais pas si c'est
votre avantage ni al'avantage de nos
radios us quoi faire oui je vous laisse
réfléchir
ah oui et vous me direz à la fin de la
rubrique à brac tel n'est pas le monde
ils n'ont qu'à pas très sincèrement s'il
veut pas qu'on le montrera pas alarmer
moi c'est pas moi c'est les caves l un
de vos mister non c'est pas vrai ouais
quoi comme la dernière fois encore un
peu un peu comme quand vous secret avec
beaucoup de points quoiqu'en sur la
voiture de deux nouveaux noms à autre
chose autre chose ils nous ont battus ne
monte pas si on peut lire ce que je m'en
fous et nous
et pour moi c'est tout réfléchi
alors pour finir sur les qualités de
syrie où ça il est très créatif
récemment son cerveau fécond avait une
idée du jeu décollant du côlon où chaque
père dont il devait se mettre un bas sur
la tête
vraiment une brillante idée le syndrome
c'est que quand tu laisses un bas devant
jean michel mr qu'a priori il y en a
jamais vu de sa vie
j'en ai chen bin saad et orteils
parce qu'il avait devant lui ce n'était
pas un bas par contre ce qui l'a le plus
intrigué c'est de savoir à qui pouvait
bien appartenir se bat mais comme
personne vais lui répondre
il a cherché tout seul
alors les bras
et si plaisir à la directrice des
programmes français savoir que voilà un
bel hommage c'est un bel hommage bon
l'info du jour c'est kenora ne porte pas
de bas
comme j'ai les images mais comme
vérifier à je peux pas le croire
non je plaisante il était alors là c'est
moins et 23 enfants sont couchés encore
les enfants ne sont pas couchés mais les
enfants s'ils sont pas couchés je vous
regarde
mais je peux montrer quand même autre
chose coire est secoué par ce que fait
gilles verdez quand une femme se frotte
à lui non j'aimerais bien savoir où il
va il la déshabille non uniquement par
la force de l'esprit
là c'était juste après une petite
embrouille à l'antenne
niveau de sa carrière
c
non non non non c'est à désespérer
oui c'est lui messi
la glisse la cellule a dit bernard
lemoine ont été très bon début mais ça
ce que vous pas regarder mais des
fluides un vrai que les autres oui
donnez pas du tout et quand il a regardé
et voulait plus m'a regardé droit donc
littérature moi non mais c'était joli un
merci et n'aura pour le panorama et nora
qui est une vraie professionnelle on la
vit tous talents qu'elle a sauté mais
aussi tous les jours pendant le
générique de début il faut savoir
qu'elle vérifie qu'elle n'a rien oublié
en loge et qu'elle a bien tout son
matériel à
ouais
eh bien on est bien mise en avant et
laura et moi alors si vous êtes naturel
voilà on est naturel à toul wright
mais cette check-list est intéressante
mais je ne sais pas ce n'est pas un truc
féminin une angoisse wacom vérifie sur
un autre génériques
moi si vous aviez tous aller
vérifiez régulièrement âme soeur mon âge
en plus vous dis je peux perdre un
ovaire excusez là vraiment si vous nous
rejoignez vite et personne à ce problème
comme ça aussi bien à l'extérieur on
dirait qu'elle est un vrai qu'elle est
chef d'une secte avec cette ville vous
avez vu que j'avais mis des tubes
puisque je pensais que j'allais faire
des choses mais si on a rien compris à
la vie d'êtres humains elle pensait
qu'ils allaient faire des choses que les
garçons qui sont tarés dans cette
épreuve alors détendez vous les filles
et les mecs de l'équipe ne regarde pas
vos attributs pas du tout à part
peut-être tiré jean-michel alors eux ils
se cachent mais marché des porcs c'est
exagéré
oui vous avez raison cession des ports
chômage en liberté a ajouté
attendez regardez les ils regardaient
les fixes et isabelle morini bosc
j'en ai vu des lourds mais alors la
la tunique rouge lui assure la patronne
des dommages sur l'emplacement
le 3 mai
ça bouge ou faux c'est toujours
non lui il croit toujours qu'il s'en
sorte aussi notre conversation je sais
pas ce sera une autre attaque hors de
question quand viendra la méchanceté de
ces hommes c'est abominable alors
thierry peut se le permettre c'est vrai
parce que thierry ils étaient sept jours
il est top
il est jeune facile il est très jeune
enfin région il part comme un jeune mais
vous avez fait 50 ans oui oui vous ne se
voit pas cette jeune bété jones en
comptant celles en basse kate et tous
mes baskets pas que ça c'est le langage
du voile comme un jeune femme comme un
vieux qui se croit jeune a alors quand
il fit est très open sexuellement
parlant on dit qu'elle est chaude comme
une braise baraque à frites baraque à
frites
bien sûr oui quand il veut faire ça ça
c'est pas la même chose
oh oui ça c'est elle
je comprends jean-michel chaude comme
une patate rappel pour ceux qui nous
redonne que thierry moreau ne devait pas
être là ce soir il devait dîner avec
jean claude van damme et on est allé le
chercher au restaurant voilà il jean
claude van damme il a jamais pensé du
navire enfin il nous a laissé un message
mais avec vous mais plus tard
ultérieurement
jean-michel suis plus surpris qu'il soit
méchant parce que fossard que avec les
invités les nettement plus sympathique
par exemple regarder le lors de la venue
de theix
ou déroule la taxe en plus c'est lui
c'est une horreur ce matin c'est surtout
moi qu'on prend plein la gueule
bah oui mais non est ce que vous savez
faire mais c'est vrai c'est un montage
grossier après j'ai pas survivre avec un
autre invité peut-être ah ouais on peut
vérifier car à travers une autre vie tes
parents de la semaine dernière la venue
de zaz il était sous le charme
jean-michel regarder le pire c'est
qu'ils aiment friends le vase parce que
oui déjà
grâce à elle il a pris l'anatomie
regardez comme ils placent bien ses
organes
la main sur le coeur
et là c'est vraiment la chaîne gfa parce
que si c'est vraiment là soit à une
descente d'organes mais alors cyril
aussi à dans les chansons de zaz surtout
y en a une que vous aimez beaucoup
il a plein et éblouis par la nuit ah oui
oui regardez aussi ça et je t'attends
jusqu'à une psychopathe
c'est laid
je me vois dans quelques années est
comme ça vous êtes déjà comme ça la plus
gentille de l'équipe vous le savez c'est
isabelle facétieux c'est pas ben non
même si on aime beaucoup ses emails est
la bonne qualité apprécié j'aime
beaucoup en moi c'est un petit texto m a
dit qu elle nous regarde et israël n'a
pas pu venir pour des problèmes
personnels on embrasse fort valérie très
très faim voilà et pour le moment c'est
vous la plus gentille et ça c'est vrai
je lave ou aussi savent assistera tout
ça autour du cou quand même quand même
ce podium mille attentions
il me dit qu'ils allaient sceller
chroniqueuse andorre qui a toujours
quelque chose à dire dans l'émission
donc pour te rendre hommage isabelle
j'ai décidé ce soir de faire une
compilation de tes meilleures tentatives
d'intervention et chaque grand cette
émission non
mais non mais ça aussi porté par les
lois aubry qui l'a choisie par le jury
maintenant j'attends d'avoir les
qualités qu'on va voir on va parler vrai
nom du jury et ensuite morgan serrano le
patron de la radio et n'y arrivons
aujourd'hui la peau
les 21 tout physique ce soir quoi vous
voulez vraiment faire un truc pas
j'aurais bien aimé faire
elle était suivie c'est sauter un nom
maintenant de changer
non il va aller jusqu'au bout de son
défi
non non non c'est un plaisir pour toi
c'est comment il a géré non quoi voulez
le faire ou pas non je voulais ce qu'on
pouvait pas faire un mix quoi il saute
il la tient dans ses bras avant on va
perdre on va perdre les deux bêtement on
va pas sauter à deux c'est possible non
mais bon bah on enchaîne je repars je
peux pas faut toile à la jetterait
pendant la fin de la saison j'ai ramené
j'aimerais bien voir l'opportunité de le
faire
d'accord bah oui merci j arrive moi mais
j'ai loué ce soir
crois que j'ai une plateforme tu vois
quoi as tu envie d'aller y aura trois
jeté à la foire du trône maintenant non
mais franchement en quoi voulais pas le
faire ce soir
non mais je vais l'essayer la vie y est
où l'équipe est bonne on est noyé pas
est arrivé quand tu t'en fous tu sois
caméra comme ça sans me l'avait lui même
s'il est équipé
c'est très drôle vous êtes très drôle
tous les doigts côté un jeu sans compter
un truc alors je suis content que
christophe carrière soit là ce soir le
chanteur des bb brunes
gallo à un déjà parce que c'est mon ami
et surtout parce que pendant les pauses
il apporte toujours sa bonne humeur à
messi c'est un vraiment bien on sent le
cricri il a un don les regarder comme y
réussit entrer tout le monde dans son
sillage
en fait des belles chronique aujourd'hui
et demain c'est la fête way
non
ouais
totalement totalement le plusieurs
titres wii hd
ils tuent jamais de mal de personnes
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai jean
christophe firmament avec 13 ans parce
qu'il parle assez souvent sonné dirait
du mal mais je vous rassure ça se passe
pas toujours comme ça je dirais même
qu'ils aient une belle osmose entre
christophe égide alors la séquence qui
suis n'est pas spécialement drôle mais
pour une fois qui est une belle
complicité dans les miens pour vraiment
un peu pour être heureux
oui
des rayons servent à christophe tout va
bien huawei non mais ça va très bien je
suis pas là ça va bien ça le jean-luc
j'ai toujours en tête à la révélation
des n'aura bien sûr que vous ne savez
pas si vous allez l'a montré ou pas pour
moi la décision es prise déjà oui pour
moi je voulais la donne est tout de
suite ou pas trois mois pour moi faut
montrer on montre tout voilà donc si
elle a une révélation à faire même si
c'est sur moi je vais vous laisser
réfléchir encore un peu plus vraiment
quoi c'est chaud non non c'est pas chaud
en plus je vais vous dire environ
non c'est une théorie c'est une théorie
d'enora sur vous d'accord voilà très
bien on va avoir su alors c'est
compliqué la solitude vous savez et
comme gisèle et là bas je pouvais pas ne
pas repasser le plus beau vent de
l'émission depuis septembre
c'était lors du passage d'isabelle
mergault dans notre émission
ses origines brésiliennes
musique jusque sur la route 1
salomé ya ça des meilleures scènes de
films classiques pour presque finir
parce que après doha le petit dossier
conversation surréaliste de titi et
jean-michel alors vous connaissez les
principes de leur relation titi fait des
blagues et jean-mi ne les comprend pas
et parfois il bug comme ce jour où nous
recevions ary abittan n'en sera rien
habitants c'est le seul comique si ces
licences est le seul que
non mais ce cognac est une arrière ces
propos lui arrive
ici à tous et sur tout mais ce à quoi
pensez-vous quel rôle on commence à s'y
rendre en suisse
l'image qu'il va préparer ce serait pas
pareil habitons à l'appareil
mais c'est un génie alors alors c'est
donc c'est une révélation des n'aura en
tout cas une supposition est normal
qu'on peut la passe et moi je ne sais
pas de quoi tu parles mais je ne vais
pas le choix en près d'un mois
moi je moi je pense qu'il faut tous
passés en plus les suppositions
remarquable qu'un à fond et une question
que franchement soit que personne ne se
posait
kaka on a pris ce que tu faisais cloud
et fois avec escales désolé mais c'est
vrai que s pose des questions bizarres
c'est magnifique
regardez tu vois je te protège te dire
un truc je crois de serre il fait bien
que toi franchement je le prends bien
mon prend bien et c'est euro puisse
convenir
comment voulez vous j'ai une question
pour notre copine valérie ah oui je veux
bien allez c'est parti
drôle bonjour je m'appelle rachel depuis
qu'elle est tombée sur la tête je trouve
valérie bénaïm plus hargneuse dans
l'émission
donc je voulais savoir combien de fois
est tombé n'aura pour est dans cet état
là